- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- I'm very happy to be here today
to talk about a topic that's
very near and dear to my heart,
which is the role of
technology in human evolution.
In fact, if you go back about 60 years,
it was a pretty much widespread viewpoint
that technology and toolmaking
was absolutely central to human evolution,
and in fact perhaps
definitive of our species.
This was graphically
represented film in 1968,
2001: A Space Odyssey, which depicts
this critical turning
point in human evolution
when this Australopithecine
male, of course,
realizing that he can use a bone as a club
and then proceeds to
slaughter his rivals with it.
From then, our future was
assured and virtually inevitable.
In triumph he tosses
the bone up in the air,
spins around, and then,
on the way back down,
it very smoothly, at least
in 1960s cinematography,
turns into a spaceship.
So you get the picture, right?
But already by the time
that this film had come out,
and you saw this quote
in the last presentation,
this vision of man the toolmaker
had started to unravel a bit.
As Louis Leakey famously quipped,
"Now we must redefine man, redefine tool,
"or accept chimpanzees as human."
And in fact, now we know it's
not just the chimpanzees,
it's not even just the primates.
If you're willing to accept
kind of covering yourself
with a coconut as tool use,
it goes into molluscs even using tools.
And as archeologists, we
also know that the earliest
appearance of flake stone
tools was not really
the transformative
breakthrough that we thought.
The first stone tools appear
around 3.3 million years
and then nothing happens.
In fact, the graph should
probably look more like this.
You have a little bit of a
flash, or a flash in the pan,
let me get the laser pointer up here,
at 3.3 million years ago,
then a whole lot of nothing,
until about 2.6 when you have some
low-intensity mucking about in toolmaking,
but it doesn't really take off
until after two million years.
So maybe early stone tools really aren't
that much of a big deal after all.
But obviously I don't believe that.
And in fact, you could say that
the termite probe here is a
tool, the phone is a tool.
You know, they're the
same thing qualitatively,
but quantitatively there's a massive
difference in complexity
that we need to explain.
So take this famous scene from
Shibuya Crossing in Tokyo.
Arguably there's not a single
natural thing in sight here.
Even the people, even the bodies,
the human bodies have been transformed
by this long engagement with technology.
The reduction in the size
of our jaws and teeth
and our gut from external
processing of food,
the adaptations to the hands and arm
for dextrous manipulation, and of course,
the very large energy-hungry brain.
But the other thing to
notice in this picture
is how many people there are.
Despite this really expensive brain,
the very long development,
the heavy investment that children require
that you may be familiar with,
there's more than seven
billion of us on the planet.
Compared to the other apes, human mothers
have the shortest interbirth interval
and the highest total fertility rate
despite having these
really expensive offspring.
So basically, they should not
be able to afford to do this.
Human women should not be able to
afford this rate of reproduction.
So how they do it is they do
receive assistance from others.
This could be fathers, could be siblings,
could be grandparents, other
members of the community,
in a strategy that's been called
a human biocultural reproductive strategy.
But obviously, for these other individuals
to provide assistance to human mothers,
they have to produce more than
just what they themselves need to survive.
And throughout the life
course, chimpanzees pretty much
produce what they consume and
consume what they produce.
Except for maybe a little bit of nursing
right here at the outset,
it tracks closely.
Now humans, we have this
long, very expensive childhood
in which we are producing much
less than we're consuming.
But eventually, we're able
to start producing a surplus,
and the reason for this
is what I call technology,
these culturally inherited,
passed-on techniques
for exploiting the environment.
So this describes a human
technological niche.
What you've got here is a powerful
biocultural feedback cycle where
technology can increase production,
which provides the resources for sharing
which can subsidize long expensive
development in population growth,
which makes it possible to grow
and educate a large brain,
which makes it possible to have
further technological
innovations, and so forth.
Now, as I articulated there,
this suggests a very
powerful, as I said, feedback,
or even a runaway feedback curve,
so maybe we're back to the, you know,
guy tossing a bone in the air, after all.
Once it gets started how do you stop it?
But in fact, not every
technological innovation
is necessarily gonna be a gamechanger
that is going to increase your production.
Increase in intelligence may lead
to greater refinement of toolmaking
rather than some kind of innovation.
And so, models that take the interaction
between some of these
variables into account,
well they can produce
this exponential curve,
but they can also produce a series
of steps and plateaus
that's a lot more like
what the archeological
record actually looks like.
So unfortunately things are complicated.
Life is complicated, and we have to turn
to the actual archeological record
and try to figure out what
happened, when, where, and why.
So why didn't the earliest
stone tools take off?
Why wasn't this a gamechanger?
So, if you've ever loosened or tightened
a screw using the knife you happen
to have in your hand rather than
digging through your tool chest
to get a proper screwdriver,
or if you've weighed
the costs and benefits
of updating your operating system,
you know that technology comes
with both costs and benefits.
So for instance, you know,
technology might increase
your rate of return, but before
you can start employing it
you may have to gather raw materials,
you may have to actually
produce and maintain the tools,
and critically, you've gotta learn
how to do all of these
things before you can
even start harvesting
form the environment.
And in some circumstances
you'd be better off
to just start right in
with a simpler technology
rather than wasting all of this time.
I'm going to focus, well
actually the argument here,
to make it explicit, is that this could
help to explain some of the patterning
that we see in the archeological record.
I'm going to focus in
particular on skill learning,
the cost of skill learning,
because this is something
that, evolutionarily,
brain evolution could mitigate the costs
of skill evolution, of
skill learning, I'm sorry,
and also changes in our donation
of time and energy in
the form of teaching.
So sharing our time and
energy to teach others
could alter the costs and benefits
of investment in skill learning.
So chimpanzees, apes, can make stone tools
But they don't do it in the wild.
And in fact, it takes
them a really long time
to learn how to do it and how to make
tools that are, frankly, not very good.
So it's really no wonder that
they don't bother to do this.
Now part of the reason,
and Dr. Fragaszy talked
about some of this,
part of the reason probably
has to do with their hands.
So they have these very long fingers
that make some of the
manipulations of stones
that we do for stone toolmaking difficult.
But I think that there's more
to it than just the hands.
So for reference, here
is a skilled modern human
making simple stone flakes.
These sharp pieces of
rock that are coming off
are surprisingly effective
knives, actually,
you can use them to butcher
a wide range of animals.
And what's required here is to identify
the appropriate geometry on the stone,
to very dexterously
manipulate and support it
with the left hand while delivering
very forceful and accurate
strikes with the right hand.
Now this is not rocket science,
but it does require some pretty
sophisticated spatial relationships
as well as some highly skilled
manual movements and control.
So I don't think it's just the fingers,
but I think it's also the
brain that's involved here
that makes this easier for humans
than it is for chimpanzees.
And in fact, humans have
an expanded neural system,
a dorsal stream, for relating things
like spatial relations, body positions,
object identification and kinematics
to technological goals,
that I think makes it
easier and less costly
for humans to learn these kinds of skills.
And in fact, this is exactly,
and if you do a functional imaging
of the systems that are activated
during simple stone toolmaking,
this is the same network of structures
that you see involved there.
So, if we turn to Australopithecines,
with their small brains,
with large jaws and teeth
and guts adapted for digesting
unprocessed kinds of foods,
with hands and arms that may or
may not have been up to the task,
it's probably the case
that stone toolmaking
just wasn't really worth it
for them as an investment.
The exception, then, that
proves the rule here,
is the Lomekwian stone toolmaking,
which actually was produced using
less demanding techniques
like indirect percussion
against a rock, a
stationary rock like this,
or bipolar shattering on an anvil.
And you can see that the experimenter here
actually has their fingers bound together
to make this point, it requires a lot less
demanding kind of manipulation.
So less investment in
skill, but perhaps also
less payoff in terms of the
effectiveness of the technology.
By 2.5, 2.6 million years ago,
we do have evidence of
more skill-intensive,
more dexterous freehand flaking,
like what we saw in that video,
from sites, the site of Gona in Ethiopa,
where I worked with Dr. Sileshi Semaw.
And you can see some of these tools
are made very finely, very small.
Some very delicate flaking
and precise gestures involved there.
And arguably could then be
a more efficient technology
that might have a better payoff.
We don't really know very
much about early Homo
that was around at this time,
except the teeth maybe
are a little bit smaller.
We could speculate the brain's
also bigger, we don't know.
Australopithecines also
around at the right
time and place to make these tools
don't show any obvious
adaptations for toolmaking.
And the sites on the landscape
remain rare and somewhat ephemeral.
So this is maybe sometimes worth it.
And it's only after about
two million years ago
that we see what I'm going to
loosely call habitual toolmaking,
though I think John Shay,
who we'll hear from,
has a different definition of habitual.
But I just mean, in the sense that they're
doing it much more frequently,
the sites are larger,
they are denser, they occur across
more of the continent, it persists.
And this is interesting
because there's a, you know,
a pretty loose, we like to
do these correspondences,
between this shift in the technology
and the appearance of evidence
of larger brain and body size.
And it's pretty rapidly after that,
by 1.8, 1.7 million years ago,
that we see the invention of
an entirely new technology,
what we call the Early Acheulean,
where for the first time
tools are being made
to an intentional shape, imposing a point,
these things we call picks and hand axes,
which are often made by striking
a really large flake
off of a boulder core,
which requires a whole different technique
and different kind of manual skill
and seems to go hand in hand
with the appearance of Homo
erectus in the loose sense,
with larger brains and body size.
This, then, appears to be
a fairly stable adaptation.
With or without hand ax, hominids are able
to inhabit diverse environments
throughout Eurasia,
even up to the edge of
the Boreal zone here.
And in places where hand
axes were made consistently
throughout this period,
like in East Africa,
there is some evidence of
incremental refinement,
but overall things seem
to be pretty stable,
if variable, stable but variable
for about a million years or more.
And it's by then about
half-a-million years ago
that we see clear evidence that we've
entered into another
period of abrupt change
indicated by rapid encephalization,
by the expansion into new habitats,
and by the appearance of new
forms of technology as well.
And one of these that I've studied
in some detail are Late
Acheulean style hand axes,
like this one from Boxgrove in the UK.
And, in contrast to earlier tools,
earlier hand axes, these
are very nicely shaped,
and especially, made very flat
and thin in cross section.
And I emphasize that because that's
actually a very difficult
thing to achieve with a rock,
by hitting it with another rock.
You start off with a big
nodule, irregularly shaped,
and you have to flatten that thing down.
And the only way you're
going to be able to do that
is if you can strike flakes that travel
more than halfway across
the surface of the rock.
And to enable that kind of fracture,
you really need to be able
to delicately adjust the angle,
the placement in the bevel,
of the edge relative to the midline,
in order to ensure that the flaky strike
is going to actually travel
some distance along the core face.
Archeologists call this
striking platform preparation.
And this entire technology
is a very demanding one.
So, in order to find out
a little bit more about
exactly what goes into
learning how to do this,
we recently ran an experiment
training modern people
to make these kinds of stone
tools, about 20 people.
They received close to
100 hours of training,
each from an expert stone
toolmaker, Dr. Nada Khreisheh.
Their products, and
we've collected all kinds
of information about these
people and their behavior,
their lithic products I'll talk about,
the actual tools they made,
have been analyzed by Dr. Justin Pargeter
in my lab as well, he's
my current postdoc.
And what we found is a
classic power learning curve,
in which early progress is rapid,
but then it asymptotes off to pretty much
a plateau of diminishing
returns from practice.
You may be familiar
with this kind of effect
in sports or anything like that.
It's found across a wide
range of different skills.
Things being as they are in life,
although we tried to
control training time,
there was some variability in how often
people were able to make it
into the lab for training sessions,
and we found that not only is it
the total amount of practice
that you've racked up,
but it's actually the
density, the frequency
and intensity of your practice,
that helps to determine individual
differences in the
progress of skill learning.
I wanna point out here that this scale
is actually a five point scale,
so the top is not even
being shown on the graph
because nobody even got
close to it in 90 hours.
We could extrapolate, from
individual learning curves,
the people in our study, we expect,
would've taken anywhere from 121 hours
to over 400 hours to achieve mastery
comparable to what we see at Boxgrove
in this kind of toolmaking.
This is a very substantial
investment of time,
especially considering that we've
given these people everything.
They don't have to gather their tools,
don't have to make their equipment,
it's all right there for them.
And we're still talking several
hundred hours of dedicated practice.
And this, to us, begins to suggest
that we may be starting to see
some of the kinds of
support that modern humans
provide for the transmission
of complex technical skills,
everything ranging from
intentional demonstration,
perhaps explicit teaching,
certainly social support,
coaching, scaffolding, and encouragement.
So the social context
is a very important part
of what's evolving here in
the technological niche.
The other thing, of
course, is that learning
complex skills does
require complex cognition,
and during this initial
jump in performance here,
we found that individual differences
in how rapidly you
kinda learned this skill
were related to your performance
on a classic neuropsychological
test of set shifting.
Basically, you have to match
this card to one of these,
you can match either on
shape or color or number,
and your ability to do that,
they keep changing the rules,
your ability to recognize
when a rule has changed
is your set shifting ability.
And if you temporarily mess
with the part of the brain
that controls this, in the
right inferior frontal gyrus,
with a magnetic pulse,
it slows people down
in being able to put together
complex action sequences.
Not coincidentally, this
very same part of the brain
is what we consistently find to be active
in functional imaging studies
of people making stone tools.
It also experiences changes
in white matter connectivity
during training.
In fact, these changes are paralleled
by species differences between
humans and chimpanzees,
and particularly this right hemisphere
inferior frontal gyrus.
So we can say that evolutionary changes
to this system in humans parallel
the effects of toolmaking training.
The remaining question is, you know,
whether this is genetic
adaptation to toolmaking ability,
or whether it's the developmental context
of growing up in a technological niche,
or some combination of those two,
which is obviously the most likely thing.
Anyway, it's going to be complicated,
but hopefully, by continued study
of the archeological record
and focused experimentation,
we can begin to sort out
some of these details
of the very extended
and multistage process
through which the modern human
technological niche evolved.
Thank you.